[Musique]
cette série est inattendue depuis le
instant 1
la maison de papier de l'histoire d'un
flop après flop ok les gars
Allez, on se verra dans d'autres projets.
et tout à coup
aujourd'hui il l'a acheté dans le flex
tout à coup tu regardes autour de toi
encore plus que l'Espagne et tu réalises
qu'est-ce qu'un tsunami qui arrive
les gens avaient une relation avec le
selic est allé au-delà du divertissement
il faut repartir selon la bête
Donc c'était ça
quand nous sommes arrivés sur la place du peuple
les Beatles
mais bon nous n'en avons remarqué aucun
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons eu la chance de
sors ta réalité change
je pense que les gens ont besoin de symboles
nous sommes face à un phénomène planétaire
les gens m'arrêtent dans la rue en soutenant
cette série suffit
Impressionnant
c'est très excitant que les gens prennent votre
travailler et faire vôtre
montre que les histoires sont
infini et que les gens ont beaucoup
Je veux que tu leur dises
court